[Applause]
we welcome you back to cbs this morning
i'm gayle king in van horn texas
where i got to tell you that people are
nice and just as excited as i am today
why because the countdown it is on the
clock is ticking
for blue origins flight to the edge of
space at nine o'clock eastern
billionaire jeff bezos and three others
will be taking the trip
of a lifetime you could certainly say
that the new shepherd vehicle will take
them about 62 miles above the earth
so yesterday we got a last-minute tour
of the exact replica of the capsule
now this is a the capsule where they've
been training in
these past few days there are six seats
in there
i chose to sit in seat number six guess
whose seat that is
take a look um it's gonna give you your
speed
miles per hour or kilometers per hour
your altitude how high are you it'll
tell you when you
make it to space that sort of thing so
they're not wearing space suits or
anything
it's a flight suit so they're holding on
to this
i did not realize you were kind of
reclined yeah it's kind of
um similar to a lot of helicopter seats
yes and
in this position it's actually a lot
easier to take the acceleration
when you're lying down so how will they
know when to unstrap
how do they know we'll tell them so our
crew member 7 our capsule communicator
will be
coming through the speakers
we are joined now by cbs news space
contributor that's bill harwood
who has been covering space flight for
decades bill good morning to you i'm
trying so hard not to be oh golly gosh g
whiz but
this is my first radio so i really do
feel golly gosh d whiz
i know that you know this drill very
very well but an interesting thing when
i was in the capsule yesterday ben who
was giving me the instructions
when i said how will they know he said
it'll come over the speakers then he
also said
but gail it'll also be on that screen
everybody here knows how to read i would
okay got it got it so bill help us
understand what is happening here today
and why this
is so important well it really is
exciting and even if you've covered it
for 30 years like i have it you still
get pretty fired up to watch something
like this a brand new rocket
flying with people on board for the very
first time
of course what this does is is at least
jeff bezos hopes it does
is usher in a new era of commercial
space travel
where passengers can buy tickets board
this rocket fly out of the lower
atmosphere experience a few minutes of
weightlessness
and then return to earth the big
question is can bezos and richard
branson who's competing with him
sustain this market over the long haul
these are not inexpensive flights
only very rich people or governments are
going to be able to put people on board
for a long time so the question is can
they sustain this as a new marketplace
and keep it going long enough for
economies of scale to kick in
and prices to come down
yeah because right now we know about
someone who bid you know
28 million dollars we don't know how
much oliver damon paid the 18 year old
who's on board but he is a paying
customer
but they haven't told us exactly how
much he paid
so can you compare the two flights you
know richard branson went up with great
fanfare came down
was successful we're very glad about
that that is the expectation about what
will happen here today
can you explain the difference between
the two and is it right even to compare
them
yeah you have to compare them because at
the bottom line both
both passengers on both spaceships are
going to get about three minutes of
weightlessness
they're going to be effectively in space
so that's the the bottom line
selling point but how they get there is
very different
you know richard branson is using a very
futuristic looking space plane
it's carried up to 45 000 feet by a
carrier jet and then released
that's when it fires its rocket motor
soars up out of the atmosphere and then
glides back to a runway landing
now jeff bezos has chosen a much more
traditional approach
it's a booster with the capsule on top
if you want to think about it that way
just like when alan shepard blasted off
on the first mercury flight
that was a suborbital flight with a
booster and a capsule on top
so it's very similar in the design
philosophy so they ride their rocket up
they separate from the rocket in the
capsule soar up to altitude
they're going to get some fantastic
views they've got the biggest windows
ever built into a spacecraft and then
they come back down to earth under
parachutes for a desert landing
i know bill everybody keeps talking
about the size of these windows which by
the way is ginormous i have to say
you know and i actually thought it was
roomy in there but why are these windows
such a big deal everybody
the other when we're walking people did
you notice our windows did you notice
our windows they're very proud of those
windows
well they're going to give a fantastic
view i mean there's no question about
that
they're bigger than the largest window
on the international space station if
you want to think about it like that
so if you're paying for the view and
you're three minutes of weightlessness
the bigger the window i guess
the better the view but on the other
hand virgin galactic has more windows
and they're certainly sufficient to look
out and see the earth below so
i think it's it's one of those points
where if you're a car salesman you say
my car has this and the other guy says
mine has that but the big windows are
certainly a selling point no question
but but this is not a competition bill
between billionaires everybody keeps
telling us that
and can you just briefly talk about the
difference between the two you said
virgin galactic the virgin flight once
you're in you're in
on this particular rocket there is an
escape in case god forbid it doesn't go
according to plan
yeah that's that's certainly going to be
a selling point that blue is blue origin
is going to advertise
um you're right the the virgin galactic
space plane is kind of like
when you get on a commercial airliner
you're on board until it lands again and
it's the same case with the virgin
galactic space plane now
they argue that their engine which is
which is
doesn't have to be as powerful as the
blue origin engine because it doesn't
fire until you're up at 45
000 feet they have a way to control that
engine and turn it off if they see a
problem coming in which case
they would just shut the engine down and
glide back to earth but blue origin has
a what they call a full envelope escape
system
meaning anywhere from sitting on the
launch pad all the way to space
the blue origin capsule has its own
rocket motor built in that can fire in a
fraction of a second
so push that capsule away from a
malfunctioning booster and that's
something
people are going to have to think about
all right bill well listen everything's
going to go according to plan today
because these guys are ready now let's
go back to the studio thank you bill